[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 le journal ravi de vous
retrouver voici les titres de ce jeudi
15 juin 2017
comme le veut la tradition les épreuves
du baccalauréat ont commencé ce matin
par la philosophie
ils sont 7 118 1890 lycéens à avoir
planché sur des sujets divers tels que
suffit-il d'observer pour connaître
défendre ses droits et se défendre ses
intérêts ou une oeuvre d'art est elle
nécessairement belle plus que quelques
jours avant le second tour des
législatives c'est la fin de campagne
pour tous les candidats les électeurs
vont-ils confirmer les résultats du
premier tour qui ont vu les candidats
dans marche largement en tête ou
rectifier les choses pour ne pas
accorder une majorité trop importante
nous irons dans deux circonscriptions
avec les candidats une carrure de
rugbyman mais un grand coeur
l'association de bénévoles côté ouvert
organisait son sixième tournoi 7 de
coeur de jour de rugby au profit
d'associations caritatives
après avoir attiré 4000 personnes en
deux jours sous un soleil estival le
tournoi s'apprête à reverser près de
60000 euros à six associations et on
ouvre ce journal avec cette mobilisation
nationale des salariés de safran
engineering une filiale du groupe
aéronautique safran une centre et une
centaine d'entre eux ont manifesté ce
jeudi matin sur le site de saclay ils
protestent contre la vente de leur
société par la maison-mère et le manque
de transparence du groupe sur ce projet
d'opération financière je vous propose
d'écouter cif appli délégués du
personnel de safran engineering services
sur le site de saclay notre désir de nos
salariés c'est resté dans le groupe
dont les slogans que vous voyez là
derrière c'est un non à la vente
donc on sait que si on être va être
vendu dans une société de services
on aura beaucoup moins davantage et on
sait jamais il y aura des licenciements
ou un plan social
donc voilà donc les salariés expriment
leur attachement au groupe
si vous voulez
on y vos bureaux d'études je pense que
le groupe ne semble pas leur métier de
base ils recentrent leur métier de base
c'est la fabrication de pièces moteur
donc tout ce qui est études
d'engineering
ils veulent sous traiter le baccalauréat
2010 est a débuté aujourd'hui par la
traditionnelle épreuve de philosophie
dans les yvelines ils sont dix-huit
mille cent soixante dix toutes filières
confondues à avoir travaillé pendant
plusieurs mois pour tenter de décrocher
le précieux sésame notre journalisme
hype michael et demi d'euros s'est rendu
au lycée polyvalent ml de breteuil de
montigny le bretonneux
ce jeudi 15 juin 7h 45 devant les portes
du lycée emilie de breteuil de montigny
le bretonneux ces étudiants en terminale
sont tous venus avec une convocation
dans les mains et une bonne dose de
stress dans leur sac pour passer leur
baccalauréat
au total ils sont 300 élèves toutes
filières confondues a planché sur la
première épreuve la philosophie je suis
chaud la philo j'avoue que j'ai pas trop
réalisé mais bon j'ai du talent un
garçon talentueux la philo c'est
décontracté
si cette épreuve là je pense que baky
c'est possible ça va aller une fois dans
l'établissement les élèves sont répartis
dans une vingtaine de sel à 8 heures les
couloirs qui grouille et d'étudiants
sont désormais désert pour laisser place
à la concentration une atmosphère
studieuse que la direction du lycée que
les biens
c'est quand même un examen un examen
important c'est d'une certaine façon la
fin de leur scolarité pour beaucoup mais
bon ils sont préparés tout au long de
l'année donc une patrie sans que ça se
passe pas bien
après la distribution des copies les
élèves ont pu disserter pendant quatre
heures sur la raison le droit à la
liberté l'art et la culture à la sortie
premier bilan
je pense que j'ai fait quelque chose
d'assez correct quand même
je me souviens suis pas trop mal sorti
donc donc ça va je pense que c'est je
pense que je crois 11 je pense que ça
ses objectifs
au début j'ai lu le texte j'étais un peu
paniqué puisque j'avais pas du tout
compris mais après j'ai relu deux trois
fois après j'ai fait un brouillon sapin
ça de ma vie que j'ai fait un brouillon
et ça m'a plutôt aider du coup cette
débrouillons un nouvel ascenseur
émotionnel est programmée pour ce
vendredi 16 juin la 208e édition du
baccalauréat continuera avec les
épreuves d'histoire géographie pour les
filières générales politique maintenant
avec derniers jours de campagne pour les
deux candidats de la 11e circonscription
qui pour succéder à benoît hamon député
sortant battu dimanche soir de la
candidate de la république en marche
nadia r&d en tête ou de jean michel
fourgous le maire d'elancourt reportage
dernière réunion publique pour nadia et
comme un fontenay-le-fleury ce mercredi
14 juin beaucoup de monde pour venir
écouter celles que personne ne
connaissait y ait encore quelques
semaines lors de sa campagne à la
privilégier le terrain et cette soirée
encore l'occasion d'aller à la rencontre
des électeurs pour se présenter et
rappelé son programme celui du président
de macron celle qui est lui sera surtout
présentes à l'assemblée pour y voter les
lois ne souhaite pas pour autant se
couper de sa circonscription
j'ai donc décidé de créer une plateforme
collaborative et citoyenne et cette
plateforme permet aux habitants de la
circonscription de se prononcer donner
leur avis des propositions ou tout
simplement exprimé des attentes sur les
priorités qui sont celles de la
circonscription qui sont au nombre de
cinq
et cela me donne l'occasion d'échanger
avec vous avec eux donc de d'obtenir
leur leur retour leur ressenti leur
composition leur attente et d'y répondre
de manière concrète elle est opposé à
jean michel fourgous pas de réunion
publique pour ces derniers jours de
campagne mais du tractage comme à la
gare de fontenay le fleury le candidat
sait que le siège sera difficile à
gagner alors il durcit ses attaques
contre son adversaire lui reprochant de
ne pas vouloir débattre avec lui et de
jouer sur le communautarisme élu local
il fustige ses probables nouveaux
députés inexpérimentés en députés
doivent faire les remontées terrain dire
qu'ils connaissaient sa conception et
qu'il ya une loi qui arriva il doit
l'amendé et l'adapter aussi par rapport
à sa circonscription de dirhams
sera pas chez nous pourquoi voilà c'est
ça le rôle d'un député c'est pas de
vendre le gouvernement il ya déjà un
préfet a cliqué le responsable local du
du gouvernement c'est pas un député il
est là pour faire l'équilibré
donc il faut absolument rééquilibrer
dans mon avis à l'assemblée nationale
parce que là on est en engageant une
dans un dans un étouffement de la
démocratie et c'est toujours dangereux
lui met en avant son expérience et
rappelle ses résultats au niveau local
il espère encore un sursaut des
électeurs de droite qui s'opposeraient à
une trop forte vague macron où tous ces
électeurs des motivés qui ne sont pas
venus voter
la campagne pour le second tour des
législatives qui se poursuit aussi dans
la 12e circonscription qui voit
s'affronter le député sortant
républicain david douillet et la
marcheuse florence granger arrivé en
tête dimanche dernier chacun d'eux est
très présent sur le terrain pour
récolter toutes les voix nécessaires
reportage camille lambert
[Musique]
c'est sa première campagne mais florence
grands juges semblent parfaitement à
l'aise au contact des passants le 11
juin la candidate de la république en
marche est arrivé en tête des résultats
dans la 12e circonscription des yvelines
mais derrière ce sourire confiant se
cache une victoire modeste
rien n'est gagné c'est à dire que tant
que les choses ne sont pas faites il
faut savoir rester un il faut savoir
rester modeste et puis et bien ce sont
les urnes qui parleront qui parleront
dimanche c'est qu'ils espèrent
confirmeront les résultats du premier
tour
on est satisfait du résultat du premier
tour bien évidemment mais avec un taux
d'abstention qui est important un taux
d'abstention qui avoisine les 48% dans
cette circonscription
l'enjeu du deuxième tour sera donc de
convaincre ceux qui n'ont pas souhaité
se déplacer aux urnes à poissy le
républicain david douillet poursuit sa
campagne il a récolté moins de 28% des
voix au premier tour
un résultat décevant mais le député
sortant reste combatif sa tg pour ce
second tour c'est d'être le plus
possible sur le terrain pour essayer de
faire comprendre qu'à parlementaire
ce n'est pas qu'une étiquette c'est
aussi une personne voilà une personne
qui doit aller qualité pour représenter
son territoire dans une démocratie le
phénomène d'avoir une opposition est
quelque chose de sain et est obligatoire
quelle que soit sa taille mais une
position doit être présent pour remettre
en question les choses moi je suis
quelqu'un qui se bat pour mes idées qui
se bat pour mon territoire et je me suis
tout le temps pleinement investi je me
battrai pour lui jusqu'au bout un
deuxième tour qui s'annonce difficile
mais malgré leurs différences de
programme
les deux candidats s'accordent sur un
point que les électeurs se mobilisent
dans les yeux
finir ce volet sur l'ailé sur les
élections législatives nous sommes allés
recueillir les réactions des différents
maires de saint quentin en yvelines
suite aux résultats du premier tour des
surprises des inquiétudes quant à la
composition de la prochaine assemblée
nationale réponse nicolas d'ombrie face
aux résultats du premier tour obtenus
par les candidats de la république en
marche des mers saint-quentinoise sont
inquiet pour le débat démocratique
aujourd'hui c'est un mouvement qui est
derrière le président de la république
et qui lui donne une carte blanche
dangereuse démocratiquement parlant donc
ça m'inquiète
à ce niveau là je crois que la
démocratie notre 5ème république est une
démocratie qui a besoin je dirais d'une
contestation constructive et en tout cas
d'un débat ce dont on s'aperçoit c'est
surtout en fait que le grand vainqueur
c'est l'abstention
aujourd'hui on voit bien on est dans une
véritable crise démocratique
puis il y a ceux qui ont été surpris par
cette vague balayant les partis
politiques traditionnels
alors je suis bien sûr comme beaucoup de
français surpris par le phénomène en
marche
je ne pensais pas je suis avec eux on
aurait quelques surprises mais à ce
point là je n'imaginais pas et ça se
passe partout en france
c'est un vrai paradoxe qu'on est en
train de vivre parce que je crois qu'au
fond les les gens se sont battus contre
la loi sont battus contre la loi
territoriale
je suis très surpris sur les yvelines
par contre que tous les députés sortants
issus des républicains voir de lui dit
soit en difficulté partout et en cas de
victoire des candidats de la république
en marche dans les circonscriptions de
l'agglomération les élus locaux vont
adopter plusieurs attitudes avec une
volonté plus ou moins importante de
travailler avec leurs députés
en tant que mère je me trouverai
toujours dans une position de
construction je travaillerai et j'aurai
la même exigence avec le député qui
représentera la première conception et
je pense que un député sera aussi
obligés de travailler avec le maire de
la deuxième ville de sète et sa
conception
un député c'est quelqu'un qui a été élu
par par les citoyens et moi je suis très
démocrate c'est bien évidemment nous
travaillerions avec cette construction
mais en même temps il va y avoir du
temps parce qu'il faut apprendre à
connaître la circonscription rame en
tant que maire communiste et avec les
élus communistes à la région au national
j'espère on portera notre exigence avec
la députée en marche comme avec tous les
autres il ya des problématiques à
voisins surtout en terme de circulation
donc les deux candidats en lice se sont
engagés à nous aider sur ces problèmes
là donc j'aurai à coeur de travailler
vraiment dans la proximité avec une
prochain députés quel qu'il soit
prochaine étape pour ces mères issues
des mouvements politiques historiques
les élections sénatoriales prévues le 24
septembre prochain elle pourrait
permettre de faire émerger une
opposition dans la chambre haute du
parlement
quatre ans ça se fête l'happy hour
business club le club d'affaires saint
quentinois a célébré en grande pompe son
anniversaire ce mardi 13 juin au circuit
beltoise de trappes
au programme une exposition des tours de
circuit des stands pour mettre en
relation les entreprises du territoire
un reportage de michael et me d'euros
les smartphones ont chauffé ce mercredi
soir au circuit beltoise de trappes
comme depuis quatre ans le happy hour
business club a fait le plein mais cette
fois ci pour son anniversaire ce club
d'affaires qui propose chaque mois des
conférences sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines organisé une grande
soirée pour permettre aux entrepreneurs
de se retrouver après le travail
objectif les mettre en relation dans ce
club d'affaires vous allez rencontrer
aussi bien le tout petit
les créateurs que des multinationales
t-il sodexo est à l'aise ce qu'il
etc
ou alors des professions libérales des
banques
il ya de tout une formule qui fonctionne
ils sont aujourd'hui plus de 160 à avoir
adhéré au club d'affaires c'est un
moment déjà convivial qui permet
effectivement de pouvoir rencontrer des
gens qu'on n'aurait pas forcément
l'occasion
mais tout en ayant ce côté un petit peu
raisonnons quoi c'est très très sympa
donc le club hhbc me permet de
rencontrer des partenaires les futurs
collaborateurs des clients également
mais c'est surtout de ne plus être
isolés dans ce milieu entrepreneurial où
on est souvent voilà confronté à la
solitude donc c'est important ces genres
de pulse est vraiment plus important la
prochaine réunion du club sera
programmée en septembre au golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines au
rendez-vous sera centré sur la
conférence comment maîtriser sa mémoire
d'éléphant la carte d'abonnement à
l'année est de 200 euros c'est déjà la
fin de ce cette fuite le journal merci
de nous avoir suivi tous nos reportages
sont à retrouver sur tv fil 78 points
com ou sur l'application tv fil 78
bonne soirée
[Musique]